وصف نائب المديره التنفيذيه لليونيسيف تيد
شيبان عقب انهاء زيارته لغزه القطاع بانه
اخطر مكان في العالم للاطفال ووضعه تحول
من كارثي الى شبه الانهيار وقال ان اكثر
من 220 الف شخص في شمال القطاع لا يحصلون
على المياه النظيفه وبالكاد يتوفر لديهم
اي طعام والاف الاطفال يعانون من سوء
التغذيه والمرض واضاف تيد بان 70% من قتل
الحرب في هم من النساء والاطفال ودعت الى
ضروره وقف الحرب واشار الى ان استمرار
الوضع قد يؤدي الى ارتفاع عدد الضحايا
بسبب الوفيات الناجمه عن المرض او
الجوع معنا من القاهره نائب المدير
التنفيذيه لليونيسيف تيد شيبن اهلا بك
معنا اذا غزه تحولت الى اخطر مكان للعالم
بالنسبه للاطفال حسب تقييمكم بلغه الارقام
ما الذي يجعلكم تصلون الى هذا
التقييم
لقد حصلنا على عدد 200 الف شخص قتلوا في
غزه منذ بداء هذه الحرب البشعه ال 70%
منهم من النساء والاطفال وهذا رقم لا سابق
له من الضحايا المدنيين في الحروب وهذا
لوحده مع 1.9 مليون شخص نزحوا انا على غزه
في هذا الاسبوع وفي الرفع عند الحدود
كنا خيم خيم خيم والاف من الخيم وظروف
صحيه سيئه جدا ونشعر بقلق بزاء المساله
الرعايه الصحيه وزياده مرض الاسهال وهذا
يدل على مدى ضروره
واهميه وكيف ان هذا الشيء انساني جدا ان
يتفقوا على وقف اطلاق نار فورا ودون اي
شروط علينا ان نستطيع الدخول الى كل قطاع
غزه ونحتاج الى المزيد من التجهيزات من
ذلك التجهيزات الانسانيه وايضا لابد
نستطيع ان يكون لدينا اتصالات سلكيه ولا
سلكيه لكي نستطيع ان ندير استجابتنا
الانسانيه ونريد توفير الامان للسكان
المدنيين طيب يعني هناك اوجه متعدده
لمعانات الاطفال في غزه من لم يقتل في هذه
الحرب يعيش معاناه من حيث قله الغذاء غياب
التلقيح
قله حتى غياب حليب الاطفال وهو يعني ماده
اساسيه هل لديكم معطيات محدده في هذا
السياق اول شيء استطيع قوله هو انه عندما
كنت هناك التقيت عد من الاطفال يصيبوا
جروح وهناك طفل اسمه ابراهيم كان قد يحتمي
في مدرسه في شمال قطاع غزه تعرض الى
الشظيه بيده وان لم يستطيع ان يحصل على اي
طبيب او اي علاج او تخدير اصيب بالرينا
وتسممت ذراعه وكان لقطع ذراعه من فوق
العكس دون اي مضادات حيويه والتقينا
بالشاب صغير عمره اسمها سحر طفله كانت
تلعب مع صديقاتها وفد تعرضت لضربه بمعدتها
ونقلت الى مستشفى واضاف هناك قلق حقيق
فيما يتعلق بالشروط الصحيه والظروف الصحيه
فالناس متراكم فوقه فوق بعضهم في ماوى وفي
خيم موقته بمواقع غير رسميه وتشاطر حمامات
وحنا
يتوجهون يستيقظون حاجاته في
في قدور او ما الى ذلك وثم هناك انتشار
للاسهال امراض الجلديه شاهدناها بعينها
وعندما نستطيع الوصول الى السكان عندما
تستطيع السلع الوصول اليهم فانها تشكل
فرقا استطعنا ان ننقل بالملابس للاطفال
الامم المتحده
وايضا اغطيه بلاستيكيه لحمايه من المطر في
جنوب القطاع وصولا الى وادي غزه وما
نحتاجه هو المزيد من التجهيزات ونستطيع ان
وان نستطيع الوصول الى شمال القطاع وايضا
نحتاج انه بالسلع التجاريه نحتاج للمجه
ازين التجاريين ان يقدموا ويوفروا القمح
الطحين والسلع الغذائيه لكي نستطيع ايضا
استخدام ذلك تقريبا ما حجم المتطلبات الان
الحاجه الى كل هذه المواد الاغذيه الالبسه
التطعيمات الاكل والدواء هل لديكم ارقام
تقريبيه 1.9 مليون غزي
نزحوا معظمهم لم يستطيعوا ان ياخذوا شيء
من زلهم لانها كانت قد دمرت وبالتالي حتى
الحصول على بطانيه على معطف صغير لحمايه
من البرد الملابس
للاطفال الاشياء الصحيه للنساء هذه كلها
ضروريه
واساسيه مليون و900 الف شخص قبل ذلك كانت
تصل 500 شاحنه تجار وانسانيه كل يوم اما
اليوم فمعدل هو 100 الى 150 شاحنه فقط
يوميا نحن نحتاج ان نعود الى مستوى
التجهيزات التي يمكن ان تحافظ على هؤلاء
السكان وت ترفع الحواجز وتسمح
ل السلع والتجهيزات تسمى استخدام المزدوج
سماح لها بالدخول والسماح بوصول التجهيزات
هذه الى شمال قطاع بح نستطيع عن نواجه هذه
المشاكل عن طريق الانساني والتجاري تحدثتم
عن ان الوضع تحول من كارثه الى شبه
الانهيار هل هو نفس الوضع يسري على كل
مناطق قطاع غزه ام هناك مناطق اسوا من
غيرها ليس هناك اي مكان امن في غزه ما
نحتاجه هو ان هناك وفق وقف اطلاق نار فوري
انساني ولا يمكن تستمر ه الحرب ليس هناك
اي وسيله او طريقه لاستمرار هذا الامر كما
هو لكن رغم ذلك وكر انه ليس هناك اي مكان
امن في غزه
وهناك وصول افضل في الجزء الجنوبي من
القطاع ونستطيع ان نعمل في رفح وفي الجزء
الغربي من خانيونس
خاصه بشكل خاص وان نصل الى السكان هناك
وهناك جزء كبير من السكان موجودين في تلك
المنطقتين ولكن بموجب القانون الانساني
الدولي يجب ان تمكن الوصول الى كل قطاع
غزه لوصول الى 300 ال شخص الموجودون حاليا
في شمال وادي غزه والذين هم ايضا اطفال
واسر بحاجه الوصول اليهم
وايصال التجهزات الانسانيه
الاساسيه شكرا لك ت شيبان نائب المديره
التنفيذيه لليونيسيف
معنا من
القاهره